when you look back across the history of
esports
it's incredible to think how far we've
actually come we've gone from duking it
out side by side in packed sweaty
arcades to beating the crap out of each
other at equally stinky convention
centers we've arisen from the niche
primordial grime of glorified land
parties to behold sold out arenas losing
their minds at jumping no scopes
[Applause]
of course for us it's easy to take all
of this for granted since that's just
how esports is now but for the early
pioneers of competitive gaming it must
be tough to look at esports today and
see the spoils of their labor being
enjoyed by a new generation of fans who
may not even know who they are now
fortunately a lot of these trailblazers
have been able to stay connected to
esports by getting into some form of
coaching commentating or adjacent
business ventures but there are a select
few who have been able to keep their
legacies alive by continuing to compete
at the highest level and sure they may
not be regularly hoisting silverware
anymore but they've proven time and time
again that they can still hang with the
kids i think there's no cover the ak
spread
two headshots in like four bullets
that's what you want that's why it's
forest but in the case of eric snipe
down rona one of the greatest console
fps players to ever live it's not just
about participating for pride he's not
interested in passing on the torch to
the next generation
no he wants to light them on fire with
it
open
it my god somehow 13 years after
kickstarting his esports career with
halo snipe down now finds himself more
popular and relevant than ever despite
being in what many would consider to be
his twilight years so how is it that
this og mlg superstar was able to
revitalize his competitive gaming career
in the aftermath of halo esports taking
a nosedive in popularity why does he
still insist on wielding a controller to
clap cracked mouse and keyboard using
kitties and apex legends and more
importantly with more than a decade of
tournament experience under his belt
where does he find the drive to continue
to compete
i don't have a gun
someone has to clip that dude
[Music]
okay so before we dive into snipe down
i'm gonna ask that you please like the
video subscribe to the channel and turn
on notifications there's a lot more apex
legends content coming down the belt and
it would be great if you could help your
boy out with that wonky ass youtube
algorithm alright so if you're not
familiar with the ageless killing
machine who goes by the name of snipe
down
we got a lot of ground to cover when
he's not getting berated by his teammate
imperial hal you can find him enjoying
the great outdoors i just had to show
you guys this teaching his doting
partner snipe wife how to frag out on
stream
let's go
let's go
or making a big fuss over his trusted
canine companion
chiefers
esports career spans over 10 years but
he first discovered his love for video
games and first person shooters
specifically with goldeneye on the n64
however it was after he was introduced
to the original halo on xbox by some
friends that snipe realized his
enjoyment of the genre was matched by
his talent i didn't know an xbox or play
halo or anything and i was the third
best person there behind the two people
that played like consistently every day
and they were shocked basically forced
my parents to get me a xbox after that
and they deemed me the natural from
there the natural rebranded himself as
snipe down and the skill he had with his
rifle namesake followed him to halo 2
and halo 3. now when i say that snipe is
an og
it's no exaggeration he started playing
halo professionally in 2008
a time when nintendo wii games were
topping the sales charts blackberry
phones were still cool and people threw
shoes to demonstrate their frustration
who throws a shoe honestly
this was the golden age of halo
competition major league gaming events
dr pepper sponsorships and legendary
team names like straight rippon and it
didn't take long for this 18 year old
from zionsville indiana to break into
halo 3 esports in a big way winning his
first major event at mlg orlando with
triggers down that year
you know winning my first event is
always just something i'll remember i
was playing out of my mind that event
luck was on my side i would throw a
sticky need across the map and i would
catch a foot snipe quickly established
himself as one of halo's fiercest
competitors but unlike players who'd
made names off their mechanical mastery
he had a more cerebral approach to the
game one that prioritized smart and
aggressive positioning over raw aim i
was never the
most like
talented mechanical player i never had
like the best movement i had solid
movement i could get around the map
smoothly but i never was like
stand out in movement this guy's insane
at this end but i always
out positioned my opponents and that is
up here that doesn't have anything to do
with like my individual shot
nice no one historian it's kind of weak
and
backwards top camera
oh
over the course of snipe down's halo
career he played alongside some of the
scenes best ever players and thanks to
his ability to communicate effectively
while fragging out he was able to win
event after event eric's always been an
exceptional talent um he's incredibly uh
skillful with the shots incredibly
bright decision making and and what it
takes to win in game um you know he's
always been a very coveted teammate
people want to team with him
people know
you can rely on him and count on him to
come out and win but as much as snipe
was relishing his successes
things weren't looking quite so rosy for
halo with seemingly every new iteration
of the franchise disappointing the
community the competitive scene began
waning in popularity and with it sniped
down's interest he dabbled for a while
in call of duty went back to halo 5 and
briefly returned to halo 3 but things
just weren't the same at 28 years of age
snipe down found himself at a crossroads
he could either wait for the release of
halo infinite or find a new way to
compete and create content and in
february of 2019 he found it this is my
favorite part
exciting apex legends was perfect for
snipe down unlike the majority of battle
royale titles out there at the time the
game had movement and weaponry closer to
that of a classic arena shooter it also
had controller support a must for any
halo veteran who preferred to get
cracked on the sticks and snipes
signature brand of crispy aim candy
positioning and well-timed aggression
fit apex like a glove
you drop on him drop on him drop him
drop them
snipe entered competitive apex as a
member of team reciprocity the
organization that he had joined in early
2018 as part of their halo roster
although he was initially trying to
compete in both games throughout 2019 by
2020 he was apologizing for skipping out
on halo events to prioritize apex
after some initially disappointing
results with reciprocity snipe down
joined forces with rogue at n-a-a-l-g-s
online four where he showed everyone
that he wasn't anywhere near washed up
i got a nate on them
all right three two one go
on him
got him but after a couple of months of
playing with rogue an even bigger
opportunity presented itself
with team solomid now tsm wasn't some
minor player in apex their team had been
one of the scene's earliest success
stories it's just that after a thrilling
honeymoon period it became clear that
they needed to shake things up and with
abralelli choosing to step back from
their lineup tsm saw snipe down as a
perfect replacement to slot in alongside
reps and the high energy always verbal
imperial hal what the [ __ ] are you doing
but snipe brought more than just a raw
aim he brought a veteran perspective and
a refusal to keep quiet about his
opinion
even when things got a little bit spicy
three
two
one
whoa
i'm definitely perspiring from
everywhere on my head
not that kind of spicy
right man like you need to realize where
we're at
no no offense how do you not have any
batteries after that [ __ ] fight
there's no batteries you guys took them
all you gotta tell us that then but on a
team with hal and reps a team this
verbal
it worked the constant sharing of
viewpoints and sometimes arguing
led to wins for a veteran like snipe
down who was raised in the boisterous
banter-filled halo community it felt
like business as usual people think we
like hate each other or something like
we're literally just passionately
talking about it not like i'm taking
anything to heart and even alberli who
decided to dip his toes in valorant
said that the fit made sense honestly i
think snipe does a better job
than like i could have done
i i genuinely believe that snipe is a
better fit for that team in general than
i am i genuinely believe that this
iteration of the tsm roster is
the best version that's not discrediting
myself or like anything like that
i just genuinely believe that he has
better chemistry of
anything
but like i mentioned earlier
snipe isn't just a great player he's a
great controller player in a game that
pits stick flickers and mouse pushers
against each other and that's a
challenging dynamic that he has come to
relish
oh
but in the apex community
well let's just say there are mixed
feelings about controller players
specifically when it comes to the
advantages they enjoy
such as aim assist the biggest issue
with
this game
is like majority of the fights in it are
all close range or close or medium range
like you you can get knocks past like
you know long range and [ __ ] like that
on mountain key but there's no like kill
potential unless you're like pretty like
basically in within aim assist range and
being that snipe is the highest profile
controller player out there
he receives his fair share of criticism
for his peripheral of choice but he's
been quick to fire back at those
claiming that he's playing the game in
easy mode alright first off i'm using a
gold stabilizer here
everyone knows the carbine is very
accurate
i'm gonna aim right here and i won't
touch
i won't touch my joystick like you can
see me moving it in the bottom right
so
you see that
boy aim assist is so strong in apex dude
it's almost as if the game shoots for me
and i don't have to control any recoil
can you can you believe that guys holy
[ __ ] dude now regardless of whichever
device he chooses to clap cheeks with at
30 years of age most people would look
at snipe down
and say that he's in his twilight ears
but the fact that he's still finding
success on one of the best apex teams in
the world hasn't just kept him relevant
it's helped him become more popular now
than ever before and interestingly that
popularity has expanded even to japan
where he gets twice as much viewership
as he does in north america snipe down's
so big in japan that he's even started
providing japanese subtitles on all of
his new videos for a country that bought
one xbox for every 40 playstations it's
definitely strange that an og halo
veteran would be exploding in popularity
in 2021 but maybe that's what snipes
story can teach us about esports it's
extremely difficult to reach the top in
any major title and it's even harder to
stay there and once you've reached the
summit and descended from it it can be
tempting to move on from competition and
reinvent yourself in another role but
for snipe down that was never on the
agenda he's been able to effectively
adapt his methodical fracking philosophy
to an entirely new competitive arena and
despite being significantly older than
the average esports competitor he isn't
just happy to be along for the ride he's
still killing it and in a frantic
fast-paced fps like apex that makes
snipe down an outlier although he
doesn't necessarily see himself that way
getting older and becoming like a worse
gamer in my opinion is
they're not correlated as much as people
think they are i don't think i've lost
the individual skill i think i've gotten
smarter if anything i'm more tactical
when it comes out how to win as a team
so i think if anything like gaming iq
has gone up immensely from where i
started to where i am now maybe a little
bit of individual skills falling off
slightly but not enough to notice or
hinder me as a player snipe down is a
shining example of what happens when
motivation isn't just a tool but the
roaring engine that's sending you
barreling down your career path it's
stoked with the fire of every win and
oiled with the lessons of every defeat
and while it's not possible to know for
sure if the road ahead includes a
full-time return to halo once infinite
finally lands one thing seems clear
snipe down ain't slowing down anytime
soon snipe down is like a halo like
legend right like he's really good in
halo or is he just really good at
console games he's a halo legend we're
[ __ ]
no one clipped that no one clipped that
please
i'm going to grab that guy's sniper
perfection baby
[Music]
if there's any guy in the history of
counter-strike any counter-strike who
who just like flicks a switch and rolls
back the years it's forced it's not even
that he's like good for his age he's
like he's just good he's just still very
good i [ __ ] pray that i
can be
like a modicum just even like slightly
as cracked as he is by the time i'm over
the age of 30 which
isn't that far away tsmft is that what
they're called now tsmftx i'm not
calling them that